The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So again,
the equivalence point
is where you've added all of
the moles of your strong base
that you need to convert
all the moles you
had of the weak acid
to its conjugate base.
So if we have this
type of problem,
a strong base
titrating a weak acid,
the pH is going to
be greater than 7
at this equivalence or
stoichiometric point.
And we can see that in the plot.
Here is pH 7, little
arrow going up
indicating it's going
to be greater than 7.
And that's because we have
just the conjugate base left
at this point.
So again, pH depends
on the property
of the salt that's formed
at the equivalence point.
And when it is a weak acid being
titrated with a strong base--
and that's what we have here,
weak acid, strong base--
you're going to get
a salt and water.
But this salt, now, is going
to have basic properties.
And we saw this before that
sodium has no effect on pH.
Things in group 1 are not
going to have any effect on pH.
But HCO2- is a conjugate
base of a weak acid.
It is a weak base itself.
So this is going to be basic.
And so that's why the pH is
going to be greater than 7.
Remember, salt
and water problems
really break down to weak
acid and water or weak base
and water problems,
depending on what
went into a form
that particular salt.
So when you're doing
these problems,
and if you're on the exam
and you get to the end
and you know that the pH
should be greater than 7,
but the pH you calculated,
for some reason
and you don't know where
you made the mistake,
is less than 7.
If you say to me, this
doesn't make sense.
It should be greater
than 7, because it should
be basic at this
point, should just
have conjugate base around,
you will get points back
for recognizing that the answer
you gave me can't be right.
So always pay attention to
what answer you're getting.
Does that answer make sense?
I really care more about
that people understand what's
going on, than they can
do the math perfectly
in a very short amount of time.
But you'll often be asked
to calculate the pH.
So let's think about how
we would calculate the pH.
We know it's greater than
7, but what is it exactly
for this problem.
And to do that, we
need to first know
what the volume is going to be.
What volume of that
strong base do we
need to add to reach the
stoichiometric or equivalence
point?
So we had in the
beginning 2.5 times 10
to the minus third
moles of our weak acid.
So that means that at
the stoichiometric point,
we're going to form that number
of moles of conjugate base.
And that also means
that to do that we
need to add that number of
moles of the strong base.
So we need to add 2.5 times
10 to the minus third moles
of our strong base.
We know the concentration in
the strong base, 0.15 molar.
So we can calculate
that the volume we need
is 16.7 milliliters.
Now, the total volume to get
to the stoichiometric point
was 25-- that's what
we had originally--
plus this 16.74, so 41.7
milliliters or 0.0417 liters.
We can calculate the molarity
of the conjugate base that's
formed.
How many moles in this total
volume gives us a molarity
of 0.0600 molar.
And now, we can go ahead
and solve the problem.
But why don't you
tell me how we're
going to solve the problem.
What are we going to use
to solve this problem?
Let's just do 10 more seconds.
Yep, so Kb, and so if we look
at this problem for a minute,
so this is, again,
the type of problem,
it's a weak base problem.
We've converted
all the weak acid
we had to its conjugate
base, because we
added enough moles
of the strong base
to convert all the weak
acid to the conjugate base.
So the equivalence point,
all we have is the weak base.
So this is a base
and water problem.
So we write our base plus water
going to the conjugate acid
plus hydroxide.
And when it's a base
and water problem,
you should have hydroxide
on the other side.
So we can set up
this expression.
We get 0.06 molar
minus x, x plus x.
And we can use Kb to
solve the problem.
And Kb, in this case, is 5.6
times 10 to the minus 11th.
That's going to be equal to x
squared over 0.0600 minus x.
So if I was given Ka
and I now need Kb,
what do I use to
convert Ka and Kb?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And you can use Kw
to solve it, yep.
So we can easily convert
between these two.
Not a problem.
So this is how you
would do the problem.
And always remember, ask
yourself what type of problem
it is.
If it's weak base and
water, you want a Kb.
So can I use
Henderson-Hasselbalch for this?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, I can't.
And you should not as well.
So what do you do after this?
We should be able
to go from here.
We're not going to go
through all the steps.
We can simplify, pretend x is
small, make sure x is small.
And in this case, x is
quite small of 1.83 times 10
to the minus sixth molar.
From that, we have to
remember that x, now,
is the hydroxide
ion concentrations.
So we're going to calculate
pOH first and then calculate pH
by subtract 14.00 minus
pOH to get us the pH.
And now, it's 8.26.
That's above 7.
That number makes sense.
If I had stopped
and forgotten what
x was and realized
the pH was 5.74,
I should have realized
there was a problem there.
So weak base in water problem.
So we go up here.
That's Point S, the
stoichiometric point.
We have a pH of 8.26.
Now, we've added this
little E at the end.
We're just going to think
about the last type of problem
you might see, which is
past the equivalence point.
So here, you are at a
volume beyond the volume
needed to get you to
the equivalence point.
And at this point, you have
your conjugate base in solution.
But you're adding a lot of
concentrated base of sodium
hydroxide to that solution.
So the amount of the conjugate
base that you have there
is really not going to
contribute to pH anymore,
not compared to the
pH change that's
going to be caused by just
putting extra strong base
into solution.
So the pH is really going to be
determined by the excess amount
of any OH you have.
And you can pretty much
forget all the work you just
did in calculating what the pH
was due to the conjugate base,
because that's going to
be overwhelmed by this.
And I'll show you
that that's true.
So what this is then is a
strong base in water problem.
So beyond the
equivalence point now,
we're a strong base
and water problem.
So how do we do this?
And we saw this
already, but we'll just
review it one more time.
So we're 5 mills past
the equivalence point.
So we're going to figure out
how many extra moles of OH
we added.
5 mills times our
concentration, so we
have 7.5 times 10 to the minus
fourth moles that are extra.
And now, we need to
calculate the concentration.
And we have to
remember our volume.
So we added 5 extra mills.
We had 25 to begin with.
And we use 16.7 to get
to the equivalence point.
And so when you have the
whole volume in there,
you can calculate that your
concentration is 0.016 molar
OH.
Then from that, we
can calculate pOH.
And from that, we calculate pH.
And it's 12.21.
And just to convince
you that it was OK
that I forgot all about
that conjugate base--
remember, the
concentration that we
had calculated of OH that is due
to that weak base in solution?
This number, really small
compared to that number.
And if you want to
be very particular,
you can add this to this
before calculating this.
But it's really not
going to give you--
to the number of significant
figures you have,
it's not going to make
any difference whatsoever.
So this is a strong
base in water problem.
We're only going to think about
how many moles extra of OH
do we have, and what
is the total volume,
and then you're done.
So now, we've done
this whole curve.
We started at the beginning.
It was a weak acid
problem down here.
We went into the
buffering region.
We can use
Henderson-Hasselbalch here.
We can do a very
simple calculation
at the half equivalence
point, pH equals pKa.
Then at the
stoichiometric point,
we're a weak base problem.
And then we're a
strong base problem.
So you can now do the
same thing the other way.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: What if you
were given a problem like,
figure out what the
buffering region was?
We never calculated E.
PROFESSOR: Yes, right.
So we skipped E, because there
was a lot of different points.
Yeah, so if you are
in a region where
you have both conjugate
acid, conjugate bass,
you can assume that's
in the buffering region.
So you need to have both to
be in the buffering region,
if the problem only has
your weak acid in water
and initially you have
sort of zero of the other.
But if you've added some of
the strong acid, strong base,
that means you've
converted some,
but you know you're not at
the equivalence point yet.
You can assume a buffer problem.
And then pretty much, it's kind
of in the buffering region,
unless it's right
here or right there.
So pretty much
anywhere in here, you
can assume it's going
to be a buffer problem.
And when you do the
subtraction, you
should see that you
had your weak acid.
And you've converted
some to the conjugate.
And you can see that
you have amounts of both
when you do that subtraction.
And when you have
concentrations of both,
then you're in the
buffering region.
AUDIENCE: So you
would go from B to F?
PROFESSOR: So you
would do D the same way
that you did B. Yeah,
that would be the same.
And then if you want to make
sure that you're not there--
but you should know
that when you start
the problem, because when you
start doing these problems,
you're going to calculate, say,
how much moles of the weak acid
you had.
And then you calculate how many
moles of the base you added.
And if they're equal,
then you're like,
oh, I'm not in the
buffering region.
I'm at the equivalence point.
If they're not equal, if the
number of moles you've added
are lesser the strong
base but non-zero,
then you're in the
buffering region.
Any other good questions?
And we're not going to
go the other direction.
We're not going to do all
the points in the other one.
But there's a
problem set for that.
But I'm not going to
leave acid-base quite yet.
We're almost there,
but not quite yet,
because I've got to say a
little more about pKa's.
So pKa's are not just important
in titration problems.
And I want to share with you
one of my favorite videos
about why pKa's are important.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Samuel Thompson.
I'm a rising senior at MIT.
And for the past
three years, I've
been working with Alice Ting.
My project is in the field
of chemical biology, which
means that I'm a tool maker.
And I've been making
tools to allow
people to look at proteins.
We want to see where they
are, what they're doing,
what they're interacting with.
But all proteins
and all cells are
completely transparent
whenever you look
at them under a microscope.
So we use an enzyme to attach an
organic molecule-- a very, very
small molecule-- to the
protein, so that we get
the same fluorescent output.
We see a bright light whenever
we shine laser light on it
and look at it
under a microscope.
After some very
complicated research,
we came up with a very
basic problem in our design.
We had a mismatch between our
probe and the pH of the cells.
Cells typically exist
at about 7.2 to 7.5 pH.
That's what's healthy for them.
They need that.
And if you go outside
those boundaries,
they're very unhealthy,
and they behave abnormally.
And the pKa of our
probe is also 7.5.
pKa is the point where
any sort of species
is half protonated,
half deprotonated.
And our probe needs
to be deprotonated.
It needs to be in some
sort of basic solution
compared to its
pKa in order for it
to be visible, in
order for it to glow.
Since our pKa of our
fluorescent molecule
and the pH of the
cells exactly match up,
that means that our probe
is half protonated, half
deprotonated.
This is a huge problem
for our labeling,
because it immediately means
that we're at 50% efficiency.
We couldn't get more than half
of these molecules to glow.
And we couldn't see more
than half of our proteins.
Our solution was to change
the pKa of the probe.
So we changed to a
different molecule that's
very, very similar and we hoped
would work with our system
but has a much lower
pKa, 3.5, which
allows us to work through
all these neutral pHs
and these physiological pHs
and still be very bright
and still be completely
deprotonated.
A lot of diseases are
caused by mutations,
which change where proteins go.
It either locks them into
a specific compartment
or puts them in places
that they don't need to be.
I hope that my work can
be used by other people
to study their own systems.
They can use my process
to label that protein
and then look at disease
cells and find out
where that protein is
and what it's doing.
Hopefully, this can
be used to unlock
the keys to new therapeutic
methods and medicine.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So that was
Samuel-- he graduated;
he's now at UCSF in
graduate school--
and talking about his
research in Alice Ting's lab.
Samuel was my academic advisee.
He's a chemistry major.
And then in the later
part of graduate school,
he actually switched and
did research in my lab.
And so that was one
of my favorite videos.
And I miss Samuel.
Anyway so it shows an
undergraduate, just like you,
caring about pKa's So that's
why it's one of my favorites.
So let's do a couple of
clicker questions related
to Samuel's video.
And so now, consider, what
if the pKa of the probe
had been 10?
How much of it would
glow at physiological pH?
What can you say
about that probe?
10 more seconds.
So let's take a
look at the answer.
So most of it-- not much of
it is going to be glowing
is the answer to that part.
And let's just look at why
that is true for a minute.
So this is what Samuel
talked about in his video
that, at pH 7-- the
physiological pH,
they had one probe where the
pKa was equal to the pH they
were using.
And so as Samuel
told you, if we think
about Henderson-Hasselbalch,
that's
going to mean that
the ratio of HA to A
is going to be equal to 1.
It's one to one.
And so that's going to mean
only 50% maximum efficiency.
And so here you see that when
the pH is equal to the pKa,
you have equal moles of
HA as you have A minus.
So you're not going to have
more-- you can't possibly
have more than 50%
efficiency, 50% more glowing.
But then in their
design strategy,
what they did was they
used another molecule
with a different
pKa, one of 3.5.
And now, the pH is much
greater than the pKa.
And so as you go above,
pH above the pKa,
you get more and more
deprotonated species.
So if you use
Henderson-Hasselbalch here,
you could calculate the
ratio is 1 to 8,000.
So you're going to have
a lot of glowing probe
under those circumstances.
And then the clicker question
that I just asked you is,
what happens then
if your pKa was 10?
So now, you have a situation
where the pH is below the pKa.
And if we did the
math, we would see
that the ratio now of protonated
to deprotonated is 400 to 1,
so very little glowing.
So this is an important
thing to think about
in doing these other
kinds of problems.
When the pH equals the
pKa, you have equal amounts
of HA and A minus; pHs
above, more deprotonated;
pHs below, more protonated.
So let's try one more
clicker question.
And see now thinking about the
pKa's of three different groups
here for this amino acid,
which structure would you get?
Should this amino group be
protonated or deprotonated, NH3
or NH2, OH or O minus,
and OH or O minus here?
Let's just take 10 more seconds.
I know a lot of
people aren't done,
but we have a demo
that we need to get to
and a t-shirt vote to get to.
Not bad.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, we have no answer to it.
But it is D. So this
is the structure.
So here, for these two, we
have pKa's that are high.
They're above the pH, so we
expect them to be protonated.
And here, we have a pKa
that's below the pH,
so we expect that
to be deprotonated.
So again, you want
to think about, how
does the pKa relate to the pH.
So that is now the
end of the acid-bases,
end of Exam 3 material.